how secrecy enforced why why is secret
why is everybody uh holding on to their
stories so hard so so intensely people
that are within the organization like
it's hard to leak
information oh they wouldn't want to
like they're true believers they see
they see like there's a there's sort of
a conspiracy theory that runs right
through all of Scientology
which is that Scientology
um represents like an existential threat
to the powers that really control that
really control this planet do they have
a face to the powers that really control
do they have names to it like who's
controlling it's Z news homies well I'm
sure that's not what they say Xeno
embodied it's actually sort of a
multi-faceted
um conspiracy and that on the one hand L
Ron Hubbard points his fingers at like
the international bankers
okay which has shades of anti-Semitism
too yeah and then their IRS system is
going to be quickly baked in I don't
know the IRS now the the IRS is so low
on the totem pole oh as far as the I
mean the international Bankers he would
say runs everything got it but they but
use that that these Bankers um also use
big Pharma and big psych to control the
population and Scientology is famously
against
um Pharma and psych and so this is sort
of how L Ron Hubbard characterizes like
this big war between Scientology that's
trying to set everyone free and big
Pharma and big psych that's trying to
enslave everyone on the planet yeah
controlling their mind controlling their
body through chemicals and and who
controls the Press
big Pharma and big psych so there's a
lot of correlation to other kinds of
conspiracy theories yeah
oh that's fascinating but you asked the
question
um where uh why would all these people
hold on to their stories they don't they
would never want to leak like by even
anyone who would want a leak would not
even want to be a Scientologist anymore
like if you truly believe if you truly
believe in Scientology and you got your
shoulder to the wheel and you're a sea
Arc member you think Scientology is
literally the only thing that can save
every being on this planet from a fate
of Eternal Amnesia and slavery yeah
right and so it's like I mean you've
seen The Matrix right so you've got
everyone once you're unplugged from The
Matrix and you realize yeah you can get
plugged back in and live your nice life
but you're a slave that's how
scientologists see this planet they
actually they refer to Earth as a Prison
Planet
just an individual level how is it
possible to reach a person like that I
is there something you could say to that
like what's the Journey of reaching a
person like that
I personally because because when I when
I was in those shoes I say there's
nothing anybody could have said to me to
get me to change how I felt and thought
about scientology
it's almost foolproof that the more
evidence you try to present that there's
something
wrong with what Scientology is doing the
more you're just working for the Sykes
you know it's very very difficult I mean
most people who leave Scientology leave
because they have ex had some personal
experience that was just such a grave
Injustice
that it just pushed them Beyond
uh the point of what they're willing to
experience very rare I've never I'm not
sure I've really ever heard a story of
someone going yeah I just woke up you
know I just gradually realized it was
all Bs and drifted away
you know it's usually like no I really
believed and they treated me so horribly
I almost had no choice
but to leave and then the stories get
pretty crazy
meaning you don't care what's true
anymore you just have to leave yeah with
this the uh the unpleasant feeling the
suffering yeah and this sort of goes
back to
um the conversation we're having about
like well does miscavige really believe
and I said I could make an argument for
the fact that he doesn't right because I
go it wouldn't be that hard to change
the way Scientology treats people just a
little bit and you'd probably stop
losing anyone because scientologists
already believed to such a strong degree
you have to be pretty freaking horrible
to people to make them leave and that's
where you go well does miscavich even
want Scientology to expand because if he
was really being clever about it it
seems like he could at least stop the
bleeding and yet he doesn't so that's
where you make the argument well if he
doesn't then he must not want to so his
mind is corrupted to the point where
he's not able to actually be a good
businessman essentially it seems that
way
thank you
the numbers of scientologists have been
going down and down and down since the
early 90s is there a good I mean it's
very difficult to get to this number but
is there a good estimate of what the
current number of scientologists are
practicing scientologists is oh yeah I
did a video about this it's actually
quite easy to get to the number it's not
more than 35 000 in the entire world and
that's being very generous and
charitable that's I was intentionally
generous I broke it all down in a
spreadsheet and everything you know what
can you give like some insights of how
you get that information sure there's
about 175 to 200 Scientology
organizations in the world
anybody who's ever worked at these
organizations know there's not more than
35 to 50 staff members per org there's
not more than one to two hundred public
scientologists per org I broke down the
number of CR members who'd be working at
every Continental Management unit middle
Management International Management I
broke it on the mission network and I
was generous I mean my numbers were like
if L Ron Hubbard came back and they were
doing an event L Ron Hubbard was coming
back and announcing ot9 and 10 how many
scientologists could we scrape together
in every city to come to this event it
wasn't more than 35 000. now contrast
that to what Scientology says
Millions 10 million people
is this less people than there used to
be yeah at its peak it was about a
hundred thousand active members but
never the millions never no